you know
[Music]
welcome to the trooper Secretary of
Transportation thanks for having me now
Pete I am on it feels so weird to say
Pete I'm Mr Buddhism as any good druber
would do I'm taking you to your
destination well I appreciate the ride
is it true that you drive a minivan yeah
yeah I love my oh yeah us too once you
have a door that opens this way oh you
never go back that's what changed it for
us it's becoming dad's just changed our
whole outlook on cars so we have twins
uh son and the daughter one in each seat
in the bucket seats about the stroller
in the back it's great you're like
there's two kids two of us let's do this
you're like if I can figure out
transportation in America we can do this
Red Light confession how disgusting
dirty
um does your minivan get let's just put
this way there's today's coffee there's
yesterday's coffee and then there's the
science experiment right and that's just
the stuff that the adults are
responsible for oh that makes me so
happy
okay this is Ronnie good to know you
nice to meet you we asked what your most
personal favorite piece of legislation
was Ronnie would you kindly give us a
Ronnie's review yeah so I am very happy
to witness a bipartisan infrastructure
law like this being presented in my
lifetime it's amazing how the
communities who have been a little
forgotten are now able to catch up to
the rest of the world so it's it's
amazing what you're doing thank you
reading your legislation I really was
hearkened back to John Hughes movies I
Remember The Breakfast Club yeah John
Bender is a character in that movie who
lives on the wrong side of the track
right I mean think about what that
sounds ended yeah I mean the fact that
we have that phrase in our language
right there are times when a
neighborhood or an entire town is
put at a disadvantage because you're on
the so-called wrong side of the track so
part of what good Transportation can do
is is
get you across some of those barriers so
that your chances in life don't depend
on what block you happen to live on it's
a Red Light confession if you had one
mode of transportation for the rest of
your life what would it be
uh I guess the bicycle I could always
use the bicycle it's a bicycle
bicycling
how should I function on a dating app
you met love and this is what all of us
need to hear is to have hope for the
dating app yeah no it worked really well
for me I mean I just come out and uh one
of the first people that that I really
connected with was was chasten and then
we met for a first date supposed to be a
coffee okay so you were like let's be
serious and mature and have a coffee
well well and then I knew I knew what
would come next which is if it was going
well I brought tickets to the baseball
game and so I had a couple tickets in my
pocket what was the moment that you knew
I'm taking out the tickets somewhere in
the middle of the conversation I can
just tell we were clicking enough that I
wanted to like talk more and and learn
more about them and spend more time with
them so the whole point of the online is
what it makes possible offline right I
lucked out like I we had that amazing
first date and like within a matter of
weeks I knew I was in love we are in the
red light okay it's midnight you're
gonna go in your fridge and you can't
control yourself you're like I know I
have to wake up early I'm gonna be puffy
and swollen and I'm going for it because
Life's too short and I just want that
delicious food right now what is that
food um there's any pizza on there I'm
going right to that I don't even need to
heat it up cold pizza fine otherwise
cheese I I feel very strongly about
cheese I just found out I have high
cholesterol and they're like guess what
you need to do cut out Dairy I was like
no oh
what would one green step bead like for
example I'm like oh if I'm reheating
food I put it back in the Tupperware I
don't take another Bowl to create more
dishes I don't you know use fabric
softener anymore that's the dryer balls
aren't cutting it but I'm like that's my
one green step so it can be something
tiny in the moment or something big what
would one green step be that you have to
say things that kind of stress me out or
trigger me yes dryer balls
why I
your sleeve gets all twisted up in the
thing with the I don't understand what
they do I don't understand what problem
they solve they don't do their job
Justin believes in dryer balls so we
have dryer balls sorry what was the
actual question so they're making
thermostats that are smarter and smarter
you kind of make the money back pretty
quick on your energy bill uh and
obviously it's good from a from a
pollution standpoint okay so get smarter
technology for your thermostat so this
new build that just passed with the
inflation reduction act one of the
things it does is it makes it more
affordable to make upgrades to your
house to make it more energy efficient
good for the environment better for your
economics
mayor Pete Transportation Secretary of
America Pete Budaj a presidential
candidate who did so well presidential
candidate in the future
I I don't know I really don't know I'm
40. we'll see
honestly I don't know running for office
is not a prize it's it's a chance to do
something one of the best ways to make a
difference is to be in a public office
but it's definitely not the only one you
never know whether the most impact you
can have on people's lives is
as an elected office holder or national
or what I get to do you know helping to
shape everything from people's commutes
to to people's international travel and
their safety serving in the military is
one of the things I admire among so many
about you Veterans Day is coming up what
is the one thing to do in honor of
Veterans for me Veterans Day is a chance
to be involved in some kind of service
whether it's for or with veterans or
whether it's just being involved in your
own neighborhood I think is a great way
to honor that spirit I think the best
way to honor people who serve this is to
make sure that our country and our
communities are worthy of what it takes
to keep them safe wow
that just hit me so hard
you have to have
a better world out there that is worth
the sacrifice yeah I I haven't thought
about it from the inside out that way we
always look to the veterans but if we as
individuals can continue to create
communities that are worth the
sacrifices it is our job to do that
that's for all of us I want to thank you
so much for your time thanks for having
me this is fun I'll keep working on the
airports and the roads and bridges and
Subways and uh excited for you to
continue to reach people with something
positive every day and uh hope we get to
do this again
don't forget to leave me a review
[Music]